on connaissait en novembre le mois sans
tabac mais depuis deux ans dorénavant
c'est un mois sans alcool qui est
proposée par plusieurs associations en
janvier on en parle dans ce journal avec
mélanie potier bonsoir ça la rédaction
de tv 78 en quoi consiste ce des six
alors déjà c'est une campagne de
sensibilisation un peu plus discrète que
celle autour du tabac pour le moment il
n'y a pas de soutien officiel des
pouvoirs publics
l'initiative vient de nos voisins
britanniques elle a été lancé chez eux
en 2013
et vous l'aurez compris le but est donc
de ne pas boire d'alcool pendant un mois
et l'avantagé c'est que les bénéfices de
ce challenge se font ressentir
rapidement et aussi sur plusieurs mois
et oui alors une étude qui nous vient
elle aussi d'angleterre elle est
réalisée par l'université du sussex
elle nous donne quelques réponses elle
porte sur 800 personnes personnes qui
ont relevé le challenge en janvier 2018
les participants n'ont pas seulement
arrêté sur un mois mais ont diminué leur
consommation
les mois suivants ils boivent moins
régulièrement en semaine que ce soit en
jours mais aussi en quantité de
consommation alors en ce qui concerne le
court terme on peut noter une peau
fraîche et plus belle un meilleur
sommeil un regain d'énergie une
meilleure concentration et une perte de
poids ça ce sont les effets sur la santé
il y a aussi un impact financier puisque
près de 90 % des participants ont confié
avoir fait des économies
merci mélanie pour ces précisions alors
le mois de janvier bien sûr bien entamée
mais pour ceux qui aimeraient se lancer
dans ce défi il existe en un site dryden
harry point fr vous recevrez plusieurs
mails par semaine avec notamment des
astuces pour vous accompagner